and I don't want to be rude or crud here
but in my culture they say the following
some mothers when they get upset with
their sons or their daughters I wish i'
done a big massive fart rather than
giving birth to a child like
you brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that 10 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing de that you want to do but we
turn it into a money-making machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends that's daily this despicable
individual backstabber of his own people
his religion we want to know a little
bit about him and his relationship with
his mom because this message is actually
to his mother she's a Muslim I have
nothing I mean I can say nothing against
her in the sense where you know whatever
it may be there is some criticisms yes
and she is an elder she is like our
Auntie but the message is very directly
to her to our Auntie n's mother now
before we do that let's watch some
videos and understand the relationship
Nast has with his mother what kind of
relationship is this and then there are
some powerful powerful a in the Quran
which will really really make you
brothers and sisters understand how your
relationship with your kids should be
because it's not that at any cost or
anything whatever they do you turn a
blind eye
never if I had a son
like I would spit in his face and kick
him out the house I'm a I'm a father
yeah my wife might have more Mercy Etc
whatever for that matter but someone
like that who sees his people being
massacred babies being blown into pieces
and then he comes and says I'm an
Israeli first I'll say you are a scum
first then you're an Israeli actually
you might even say Israeli first then
scum I think probably that's probably
worse Zionism he has to be Z Zionist
first okay Subhan Allah so here's the
video is working to watch they very
short Subhan Allah but it will tell you
the Dynamics that he has with his wife
sorry with his mother and I'm going to
inshallah after that give you some
powerful vers from the Quran and the
story of how does this relate to this
Allah subhana wa tala is given us such a
powerful message with the story of and
two is directly telling you that your
spouse husband or wife and your children
are a fitner for you and how we should
inshallah deal with our own kids in this
matter inshallah let's watch the videos
yes here in my Arab Community it is
expected for the parents to pay for the
kids to pay for their car for their
wedding for their school college
education and even for their house and
in many of these cases parents have to
take moans it's just part of the culture
we love our kids
I too could get a free car and a free
house but I had to turn it down because
of dependence scared of getting too
dependent on parents free money my
parents and everyone's parents here are
so loving well-meaning and generous and
I feel lucky to have them but maybe the
best gift they can give us is not a car
or a house but the gift of love and
Independence my mom just called me and
told me the craziest story she was
flying from Berlin to Israel at the
security check she was asked out of to
step aside and go for a private room for
inspection that's fine as they were
searching her my mom with limited
English jokingly said that she has no
bom and that's when everything went
crazy security was informed the M16
rifles were in the room searching her
the flight was delayed and the
destination airport was informed my mom
was in tears this Elementary School
teacher mom who wouldn't hurt a fly was
treated like a terrorist I understand
the need for security but what happened
to humanity the joke is only human and
my teacher mom who rarely travels loves
to joke what my mom said was a joke but
was also a fact she has no bomb my mom
has no bomb my mom has no bomb my mom
has no bomb does your mom have a bomb
she does not have a bomb my mom has no
bomb so guys from the relation we see
sub number one giving your kids
everything I don't they say it's an Arab
culture thing yeah number one that is
wrong in itself but in no way shape or
form I'm going to blame that their
parents giving him whatever he wants and
paying for his wedan car is a cause for
him to turn out the way he turned out so
he turned out very I mean he he should
be ashamed I would be ashamed to have a
son like him I would be ashamed to have
a son like him I'm so I'm going to very
direct into the point yeah what does
Allah subh say in the Quran let's read
for ourselves brother and sisters yeah
Allah subhana tala says in the Quran
chapter 64:1 14 so powerful guys listen
to it very carefully Subhan Allah is
your loyalty to Allah subhana wa tala
and what is the H or to your kids or
your wife or your husband okay who Do
You Love
More Allah says
and in the next Ayah Allah
says so Allah subhana T is saying that
oh you who Believers indeed among your
wives and your children not wife spouses
and children there are some trial fitna
so beware of them and if you pardon an
look and forgive them their fault then
surely Allah is all forgiven very
merciful your wealth and your children
are only a Temptation and a fitner trial
and Allah has with him the greatest
reward Subhan Allah look at that and
another verse in the Quran Allah subh wa
tal says and another verse in the Quran
Surah Allah subh says
what and know that your wealth and your
children are but a trial and that Allah
has the great reward with him Allah
subhana wa tala is reminding us all of
the trials and fitness we're going to
face when you look at the story of alam
when his son when Alam made Dua and said
save me and my myself and my family when
his son did not come on the boat Alam
questioned he said oh Allah did you not
say you're going to save me in my family
Allah subhana rebukes Alam and tells him
that his family is who the Believers the
Believers are your true family because
on that day I'll be honest with you the
way n da behaving this absolute dirt bag
do you think when a a true War happens
between Israel and real Muslims and
Islamic Nations whatever whose side do
you think this guy's going to be I have
no Shadow of Doubt do you think the
Muslim armies are going to trust him do
you think they're going to trust him
they're going to think he's going to a
traitor is going to he's probably going
to be on the Israel side I promise he's
going to be on the Zionist side okay
he's going to be on the Zionist side
this is the point here Subhan Allah so
your true allies is what even in the
Battle of bad there were people who had
the other family members on the other
side this is when push comes to sh
that's when you know the reality and
Allah is telling you do not take them
subh Allah's warning you against that
and if you look at the story of in the
story of when he was going with M Alam
and he went and he killed a boy yes and
I just want to give a disclaimer
nobody's asking to kill anybody here
this just disclaimer it's the story this
hman behind the story and mam said why
would you kill somebody who's innocent
and said what some even SCH say he was a
prophet says what he says indeed he was
going to grow up and be a rightous
person that was going to lead his family
astray so the point here is what that
when a child dies and it's one of the
most painful things for our parents yes
but let me tell you something just
imagine if this man with his
wretchedness and God know lead his
family astray may Allah protect his
family on you're going to wish that
never something like that never existed
and I don't want to be rude to crud here
but in my culture they say the following
some mothers when they get upset with
their uh Sons or their daughters they
say I wish i' done a big fart instead of
giving birth to you I repeat again I
wish I'd done a big massive fart yes
rather than giving birth to a child like
you okay Subhan Allah and you know if
the shoe fits I'm sure it does Subhan
Allah that's all I want to say inshallah
and that story tells you what that
Subhan Allah sometimes we think that we
know Allah knows yes our child Subhan
Allah to for them to die something
happen to them is painful but to have in
Allah and know God know Subhan Allah
were they going to be a child that
Subhan Allah was going to go astray if
Allah's took them and Subhan Allah is
going to insh maybe they're going to
pass a test on and enter Jenna Allah has
put you and them in Jenna rather than
them growing up and going astray and
leading astray and both in the hell fire
that is the hi in the story of Subhan
Allah and I'll be honest with you w I
would be so ashamed to have a son like
this vile individual Subhan Allah who
has turned his back not only turned his
back he is supporting you can run away
you can just say you know I don't want
to talk about this issue for whatever
reasons to now go against your people
when the massacre is happening nasly I
wish I come across face to face with you
one day I will wish for nothing but I
wish I can see you face to face one day
I cannot wait for that day I cannot wait
for that day that's all I'm going to say
inshallah and this a message to nast's
Mother you are our sister and so is your
husband is our uncle I'll be honest with
you um if you guys were not Muslims I
I'll be very very harsh but W your son
may Allah subhana wa tala guide him yes
when may Allah subh guide him that's all
I'm going to say inah